(host)
Vikings were some
of the fiercest fighters
in human history,
using their impressive
battle prowess
to spread Norse influence
between the 8th
and 11th centuries.
Their bravery as warriors
was driven
by one ultimate desire:
to join Odin in Valhalla.
Only the most worthy Vikings
would get to spend
their afterlives
in that hallowed hall,
and the choice
of who made the cut
fell to a group of powerful
but mysterious women.
I'm talking about
the Valkyries.
[intro music]
Most of what we know
about the Valkyries
comes from the prose
and "Poetic Eddas,"
collections of mythology
and heroic tales
written down
in the 13th century.
In the texts,
these powerful women
were often described
as beautiful maidens
decked out in battle gear
and armed to the teeth
with brutal weapons.
Using their powers
of foresight
and mystical abilities
to sway the tides of war,
the Valkyries were said to fly
over battlefields on horses,
or sometimes they would
sport their own wings,
like the goddess Freyja,
who may have been
the first Valkyrie.
The Valkyries
were at least as deadly
as they were beautiful,
and were said to be blessed
with superhuman strength
and speed.
In some stories,
they could even shapeshift
into different birds,
Most Valkyries went unnamed,
but those who weren't
were given war-themed monikers
like Skogul,
Sigrún, or Hlokk,
which mean "shaker,"
"victory rune,"
and "clashing battle."
The word Valkyrie means
"chooser of the slain,"
and they were indeed
as selective
as their name implies.
Only half of the Norse warriors
who died in battle
were carried by the Valkyries
to Valhalla.
The rest were spirited away
to Fólkvangr
to spend their afterlives
with Freyja.
Once in Valhalla,
the dead heroes,
or einherjar
as they were called,
would spend their days
fighting and nights feasting,
preparing to defend Asgard
in the world's last battle.
Despite the power they
wielded on the battlefield,
the Valkyries' role
was relegated
to that of servant
in Odin's hall.
The mead that the einherjar
drank to heal their wounds
from training was served
by the very same hands
that plucked them away
from Midgard.
In addition to deciding
individual warriors' fates,
the Valkyries were
sometimes said to determine
the outcome of entire battles.
An old Norse poem
called the Hákonarmál
recounts how two Valkyries,
named Skogul and Gondul,
influenced
the Battle of Fitjar,
fought in Norway in 961 CE.
King Hákon the Good
faced an army
led by his nephews
who wanted to take his throne.
The poet who
immortalized the clash
wrote that Hákon
tore off his mailsuit
and, with his sword,
hacked through
his opponents' armor
"as if it were
cutting through water."
The would-be usurpers
were defeated,
but King Hákon
suffered mortal injuries,
and when the Valkyries
appeared to take him away,
he asked Skogul and Gondul
why they came for him
when he fought so well
and defeated his nephews.
The Valkyries replied
that it was only because
they were with him in battle
that he was able
to hold the field,
and his enemies fled.
Way to kick a man
while he's down.
In their capacity to predict
and sway the outcome of war,
the Valkyries were similar
to Norns, deities of destiny
who you may remember
from our episode
on the Greek Fates.
A poem found in Njál's Saga
from the 13th century
makes this comparison
abundantly clear
when the titular Daurrud
happened upon a group
of Valkyries
weaving the fate
of a battle later that day.
Daurrud spied 12 Valkyries
working around a gruesome loom
with human heads for weights
and swords for shuttles.
The thread was made
from human entrails,
and the Valkyries
sang while they wove
their "war-winning woof."
The Norns weren't
the only mythical figures
who blended
with the Valkyries.
By the time the Eddas
were written,
the Valkyries had taken on
characteristics
of the German swan-maiden.
Like Selkies
from Celtic folklore,
swan-maidens were able
to shift from their animal form
into beautiful women.
Their good looks were
often their downfall, however,
as was common in stories
for men to steal
a maiden's swan suit.
And without her feathers,
she was stuck in human form.
Even Brynhildr, one
of the most famous Valkyries,
fell prey to this avian theft.
While the man involved suffered
very little consequence,
of course, Brynhildr
went on to live a life
of punishment
for his foul deed.
According to
the Volsunga Saga,
Brynhildr was the
human daughter of King Budli,
lovely enough that Odin
picked her
to be one of his Valkyries.
One day, Brynhildr
and her sisters
were out bathing in a pool
with their swan suits
tucked away
on the bank to stay dry.
Unbeknownst
to the young Valkyries,
a prince named Agnar
was hiding,
waiting for them
to be distracted
so he could steal
the maidens' feather suits.
Brynhildr and her sisters were
stuck with Agnar for years,
and whether through coercion,
real love,
or some twisted combination
of the two,
Brynhildr ended up making
an oath of fealty to Agnar.
Later, after he returned
Brynhildr's feathers,
Agnar fought
against Hjalmgunnar,
King of the Goths,
who was favored by Odin
to win the battle.
But Brynhildr used
her Valkyrie powers
to uphold her oath
and sway the outcome.
Agnar emerged
a victorious underdog,
and Odin was furious.
His punishment
for Brynhildr's betrayal
was to banish her
to a fully mortal life,
slumbering in a castle,
guarded by a wall of fire.
An early sleeping beauty,
if you will.
Maybe you can guess
what happens next.
A hero named Sigurd,
aka Seigfried
the Dragon Slayer,
was brave enough
to pass through the flames
and immediately
fell in love with Brynhildr,
but left her behind while
he ran an errand in Bergundy.
While there, he met
a jealous sorceress
who wanted him to marry
her daughter,
so she cast a spell on him
and sent her son Gunnar
to marry Brynhildr instead.
Except Gunnar
was too much of a coward
to walk through
her protective fire,
and Sigurdr had to do it
disguised as Gunnar.
Brynhildr married Gunnar
based on that lie,
and when she found out
the truth,
she arranged
for Sigurdr to be murdered
and then threw herself
onto his funeral pyre.
I swear, modern-day
soap operas
should dip into Norse folklore
for inspiration.
Brynhildr's fascinating,
albeit tragic, life
illustrates the mystery
surrounding
the mythical Valkyrie.
She was a human woman
trained to be a shield-maiden,
granted divinity by Odin,
who made herself vulnerable
by shifting into a swan.
Scholars believe
that the basic idea
of a Scandinavian war goddess
is quite old,
but that these varying
characteristics
were added to the mythology
over time.
They all would have been
written down together
when the Eddas were composed
in the 13th century.
But that begs the question:
where did the Valkyries
come from?
One hypothesis is that
the legend arose
from the totally mundane
phenomenon
of the Norse shield-maiden.
These were warrior women
who fought alongside
male Vikings in battle.
Modern scientists
have used DNA evidence
to confirm that Norse women
did indeed fight with men,
and it's not too difficult
to see how this practice
might lead to myths
about ferocious women
who decided the fate of war.
It would also explain
why so many Valkyries
are said
to have human parents.
Another idea is
that the stories were inspired
by priestesses of Odin
in the early Viking Age.
These women would have
overseen sacrificial rituals
in Odin's honor,
literally choosing
who would be slain
in his name.
This sounds familiar,
and it would explain
why Valkyries were described
as the physical manifestation
of Odin's will
in the older mythological poems
of the Eddas.
We may never know
the Valkyries' true origins,
but we can say for certain
that they have made
a large impact
on our popular culture.
Valkyries can be found
in comics, anime,
television,
and video games.
In the 1850s,
Richard Wagner composed
his opera Die Walküre,
or The Valkyries,
which was one
of his four music dramas
inspired by Norse mythology.
This one loosely follows
Brynhildr's story
and features the absurdly
catchy tune,
"The Ride of the Valkyries."
And of course, we can see
Valkyrie on the silver screen,
played by Tessa Thompson
in Marvel's "Thor" franchise.
The Valkyrie is depicted
as a strong, powerful woman
with influence over life
and death, even today.
It may seem strange
that a culture so infamous
for its physical dominance
would hold women
in such high esteem.
But women had more rights
in Scandinavian culture
than you might think.
Their gender roles
were typical,
with men doing most
of the physical labor
and women taking care
of the home,
but women could own property,
divorce their husbands,
and often had a say
in who their parents
married them off to.
Naturally, people with
so many fierce female figures
in their mythology would
have respect for mortal women.
We clearly haven't forgotten
the Valkyrie,
so let's not forget
this lesson they teach us.
Accessibility provided by the
U.S. Department of Education.